The German defense minister on the military
airfield in the capital of Ni-A-mey in Niger.
Germany financed the modernization of the
base and German forces stationed here support
missions in neighboring Mali, and the army
of Niger.
Your country is a valuable, reliable and committed
partner in the fight against terrorism, against
organized crime and illegal migration in the
region.
We will only be able to overcome these challenges
if we work together."
Niger is one of the poorest countries in the
world.
It's the country of origin and a transit country
for West Africans heading for Europe.
The army of Niger has been unable to contain
large-scale people smuggling which has been
on the rise in recent years.
Our troops are frustrated by the lack of transport,
the inability to react quicky and bring soldiers
to the places they are needed in this huge
expanse of the Sahel, where all our borders
are under threat.“+++
For that reason Germany has provided the army
of Niger with 53 off-road trucks and has also
financed a college for non-commissioned officers.
The total cost: 11 million euros.
The defense minister also officially opened
a newly built camp for seventy German soldiers
in Niamey.
The Bundeswehr is here for the long haul.
More and more this airbase in Niamey is becoming
a hub fort he German Armed Forces.
Already Germany is supporting Niger and Mali
directly and a few other West African countries
indirectly in their fight against terrorism.